لقد فقدنا أرواحهم في تصعيد
العنف خلال العام الماضي ، نعم
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
يعاني الفلسطينيون والإسرائيليون على حد سواء من
تزايد في الأمن
الخوف في منازلهم
ومجتمعاتهم وأماكن عبادتهم
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
لاتخاذ خطوات من أجل  التراجع عن التصعيد لوقف
أه العنف لتقليل التوترات
ومحاولة أيضًا إنشاء الأساس
لمزيد من الإجراءات الإيجابية للمضي قدمًا.
الاستمرار في السعي ليس فقط للحد من
العنف ولكن ضمان أن أه في نهاية المطاف
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين على حد سواء يتمتعون
بنفس الحقوق وبنفس الفرص
أه ما نراه الآن
للفلسطينيين هو أفق يتقلص من
كلا الجانبين وليس التوسع وهذا أيضًا
نعتقد أنه يجب تغيير
[موسيقى]
أن الكيفية هي
أجنبية [
موسيقى]
كما أقدر السيد الرئيس
موقفك الثابت أه والحازم
ضد الإرهاب
[موسيقى]
من جانبنا كنا نعمل على
تعزيز علاقتنا مع
الشعب الفلسطيني  وللمساعدة في
تحسين حياتهم
[ضحك]
نحن نقوم بطرق غير ملموسة بما في ذلك
دعمنا لحوالي 890 مليون
دولار لكل شيء من الغذاء إلى
دعم اللقاحات لأه لتعليم اللاجئين
وما إلى ذلك
إيطالي
اليوم يمكنني أن أعلن أننا ذاهبون إلى
تقديم مبلغ إضافي قدره 50 مليون
دولار
عندما زار الرئيس بايدن في يوليو / تموز ،
كما خصص 100 مليون دولار
لشبكة مستشفيات القدس الشرقية
أم
توصلنا إلى اتفاق أيضًا
لتوفير اتصالات 4G
للفلسطينيين ونعمل على
تنفيذ ذلك
كان رائعًا
و  كما قام الرئيس بتسمية هارياما
الموجودة معنا اليوم كأول
ممثل لنا للشؤون الفلسطينية
[موسيقى]
وفي نفس الوقت سنواصل
العمل لإعادة فتح قنصليتنا في
القدس.